Donald Trump should have and is it being
investigated for his handling of
classified documents including taking a
whole bunch of them to his house and
then lying about where they are and then
avoiding returning them and all these
different things and Joe Biden should
likewise be investigated now the
circumstances of course are completely
different we're talking about a couple
about a dozen or so documents with Joe
Biden and we're talking about what
hundreds or more with Trump we're
talking about something with Joe Biden
where when his lawyers found out they
immediately notified the National
Archives it was the opposite with Trump
there is no evidence whatsoever that Joe
Biden asked or was even involved in
these documents remaining where they
were whereas there is widespread
testimony that Donald Trump specifically
said take these documents down to
Mar-A-Lago there are no similarities but
I am consistent investigate everyone and
everything and see where it shakes out